the comedian Stephen Wright used to have
a joke where he would talk about owning
a map with a one-to-one scale he said
that he spent a whole summer unfolding
it I don't know if Wright was
referencing intentionally a jorge luis
borges story though i think he probably
was where the characters had the same
thing they have a map with scale of one
mile equal to one mile and Boris was
trying to make a point that that kind of
map would be useless right he was making
a commentary on science how sometimes if
you have too much data you actually
reduce the amount of information have
you reduce the amount of knowledge well
let me pitch him maybe a
counter-argument to what Boris was
saying here's a map that the scale is
not one to one but like a thousand to
one at least information ly speaking
what you're looking at is a map of
Seattle courtesy of the folks at the big
construction company Parsons
Brinckerhoff and Autodesk the 3d
computer generated imagery company but
this isn't just a pretty 3d flyover I
mean it is a pretty 3d flyover but it's
generated not from an artist's vision
but from the actual information that
goes into building the building so it's
the zoning of the city and it's the
blueprints of the buildings themselves
and the the services are texture maps
pictures taken from the real Seattle so
what you're seeing is essentially the
the modern version the virtual version
of Boris's one-to-one map only built
inside a computer this is I've started
to think of this as Seattle Tron because
this is the grid right i mean this is
the actual city it's the size of the
city only it's in silico instead of in
vivo where we are now so what do they
use this form well Seattle has been
using the map to test some of its
disaster preparedness do some evacuation
modeling and I'm after the middle little
dubious about this being as useful as
they would hope it would be although
Parsons Brinckerhoff was very hip on the
idea because you know it's a simulation
so whatever unpredictable limitations
exist out in the world don't get modeled
in a simulation but they've said to me
that they're still finding some things
like oh this is where people would go
and this is what might happen to some of
the structures they're interested in in
building of rebuilding a viaduct that's
part of the waterfront in Seattle for
example so that's interesting but it's
actually not my favorite map or
simulation of the city this one is what
you're looking at now is the path of a
planned tunnel underneath the City of
Seattle so those those things that look
like pillars floating in the air that
you can see those are actually the
foundation
of skyscrapers so the tunnel is going to
go under this also has things like
utilities and and other tunnels that art
exists in the city so what this map does
is takes real information this is the
same one to one three-dimensional map
but it's it's a view that no human being
could ever have right this is a map of
the invisible city this is a map of a
city that you would never be able to see
but exists or could exist well that got
me thinking you could take one of these
virtual cities the Seattle Tron and
start layering on more data sets right
we have a lot of data that comes out of
cities all the time electronic financial
transactions GPS traces for trucks and
for taxicabs whether a traffic light is
red or green images from traffic cams
everybody's tweets and Foursquare
check-ins and instagrams map to the
place where they were actually taken and
put up as as wallpaper on the image you
can start to imagine the Seattle Tron
becoming very place like you know Lewis
Carroll wrote about one of these maps to
actually in his story there's a country
that evolves a map so sophisticated and
big that eventually it's it's near 121
and farmers start to complain because
when they're using the map it blocks out
the Sun and their crops die but what the
what the folks in that mythical land
started to do was use the country itself
as a map what I'm pitching here is if
you started to add enough data to
something like the Seattle Tron to one
of these simulations you could start to
use the map as a country right I mean
you could go there in a way so I think
maybe finally technologies gotten us to
the place where board has was wrong
where the one-to-one map the addition of
data finally makes these maps not less
usable but more useful makes real